تكاليف. او كما يقولها المصريون
الساعة بخمسة جنيه والحسابة
ثلاثين دولار ويكسر حاجز سعر
الطائرة الامريكية باقل من اربعة
اضعاف مقاتلة بوتين ولكم الخيار
يقولها الروس وسيتم اطلاق تشيك
مر وقت طويل منذ ان عرضت روسيا
ذات محرك واحد ولم تكن هناك اي
ميت بين عامي الفين وثلاثة
وعشرين والفين واربعة وعشرين.
تشير الى حركة موت الملك في لعبة
الشطرنج هي ثاني طائرة مقاتلة
ذات محرك واحد في العالم تتضمن
اكثر انظمة التهرب من الرادار
والقيادة تطورا والطائرة الاخرى
الوحيدة في هذه الفئة هي اف خمسة
للدول التي لا تستطيع تحمل تكلفة
اف خمسة وثلاثين الامريكية التي
امكانيات هائلة للتطور وصناعتنا
الجوية تستمر في بناء طائرات
افتتاحه المعرض في وقت لاحق قال
صناعة الطيران الروسية لديها
وسبعة وسبعين. فهل يستطيع بوتين
الانتظار حتى ذلك التاريخ الرئيس
الروسي لم ينتظر وها هو في عام
الفين وواحد وعشرين يعاين
الحمولة القتالية وهو رقم قياسي
مطلق للطائرات من هذه الفئة.
طائرة روسية مقاتلة خفيفة جديدة
في السوق ولا يوجد جيل خامس على
هذا النحو. بوتين يقولها للعالم
وفرنا لكم سلاحا جوي مدمرا وباقل
تصف روستيكا الطائرة بانها
مقاتلة خفيفة ذات محرك واحد من
تدمير الاهداف البرية والبحرية
نحو فعال والقتال باداء عال في
الروسية بقيادة شركة وتم تطوير
الطائرة. هذه المقاتلة قادرة على
ظروف التفوق العددي للعدو
المقاتلة اصغر حجما من اي مقاتلة
بينما ادخل الجيش الامريكي
المقاتلة اف خمسة وثلاثين في
كيلومتر ولها القدرة ايضا على
حمل اكثر من سبعة اطنان من
ولديها رؤية منخفضة واداء طيران
مرتفع وهي فريدة من نوعها في
فئتها. حيث ان لديها قدرة على
التحليق لاكثر من الف وخمسمائة
الامريكية على اقوى اسلحة الجو
لسنوات وسنوات. فقوات واشنطن
بتحسب ليتساقط لعاب الكثيرين
لحجز الكثير منها.
الوضع ويقدم بسياسة الصين
التجارية. يوجد لدينا البديل
يصل سعر الواحدة منها الى مائة
وعشرين مليون دولار ليستغل بوتين
الجيل الخامس تتضمن حلول مبتكرة
من بينها الذكاء الاصطناعي.
الخدمة عام الفين وخمسة عشر. ومن
المتوقع ان تظل حتى عام الفين
وذكرت يو اي سي انها تجمع بين
الحلول والتقنيات المبتكرة
انه عرض روسي سيغير قواعد اللعبة
في سوق سلاح الجو العالمي. لقد
وثلاثين التي تعتبر المقاتلة
الاكثر تقدما في ترسانة الولايات
واقل من سعره الاصلي وبنفس
الكفاءة ليبلغ سعر تشيك ميت نحو
شبح روسية تتميز بصعوبة اقتفاء
اثرها في المعارك تصل سرعتها
الامريكية عن عرشها. فماذا جرى?
صنع الروس مقاتلة كوش ميت او كوش
جوية وبقدرات خارقة. هنا يخطط
الروس لازاحة اف خمسة وثلاثين
المقاتلة الخارقة نتحدث وللحديث
بقية. سيطرت الولايات المتحدة
الدول شراؤها. ليأتي بوتين لدول
العالم بالحل نعم انها مقاتلة
كبيرة ومرنة عن اي سرعة وعن اي
قدرات نتحدث. لم ننتهي بعد. هنا
المسلحة تمتلك مقاتلات خارقة لكن
اثمانهن باهظة جدا ليس بوسع جميع
المتحدة العسكرية. تشيك مايت
بحسب المحللين تقدم حلا اساسيا
تنافسية جديدة. وتقول وول ستريت
جورنال ان تشيك ميت والتسمية
المقاتلة في المعرض قبيل ساعات
من الكشف عنها رسميا وخلال
الطائرة لم يسبق لاي شبح روسي
الوصول لهذا المستوى من القوة
لموسكو لا يهم ان كان الخصم
يفوقك عددا وانت تمتلك هذه
حتى جاءت هذه المقاتلة لتكون احد
اقوى الاسلحة لبوتين. عن
قدرات خارقة وباقل التكاليف. وحش
الجو الروسي والمقاتلة الاقوى
القصوى بالف وتسعمائة كيلومتر في
الساعة. تتمتع بمجموعة تسليح
ملك او تشيك مي بالانجليزية
اجتمعت اقوى وافضل شركات التصنيع